of Canada has not only done blackface
he's done it like 15 times damn really
this is the prime minister this is the
worst one
oh oh
wow the chasm between white and black
Americans is growing wider with each
passing day HS culture General outlook
on life are so different that even
living in the same Community sharing the
same space is something that's almost
unfeasible at least that's what you'd
believe if you're an avid consumer of
Legacy
Media if the World falls apart trust
should not be dled out easily to anyone
especially white people here's the thing
I've noticed and and you can comment if
this is the same for you it doesn't
match up at all with my lived
experiences and that's what's inspired
me to actually deal with the lives of
these Legacy Media Outlets refuse to do
get out into the community and have real
conversations
with average Americans black Americans
white Americans not caricatures of what
the media thinks black people are people
like van Jones black people are at risk
from police in the latest installment of
this series I made my way to a cultural
mainst in modern black American society
the barber shop because really what
better place to find authentic
unfiltered perspective than the place
that's iconically known as the breeding
ground for ation in the black
community and what did I find are black
and white
Americans as far apart from each other
as we've been told well see for
yourselves this is black and white on
the gray
issues you uh you want to do your
beard good what are you going to do you
going to make me look like a photo
negative Drake or
some I can clean it up all right okay
man go get cleaned up man well I asked
him earlier said he was too busy no no
at that time
okay we
don't people go people don't get their
like well most people most from my
estimation most people are afraid of the
backlash that's just going to come with
it if you get it wrong yeah you know
whereas you know I think you have you
have the room to be wrong if you don't
know but who's to say that you wrong
like say I one of the things I agreed
with you with was so what you're saying
is so for all this time that this has
been correct now this short amount of
time everybody's got to change on the
dime yeah and and and come to the other
side that's going to be hard yeah it's
gonna be hard to to change my I'm I'm
I'm a hear and a heard that's that's it
that's about all I got yeah I know that
offends you I can call you by your name
but that's yeah exactly you know look I
think they always try to misconstrued
right this is we're talking like the
bide and Conquer from the media it's
like look just because I think that male
and female is a thing doesn't mean I
hate you doesn't mean I hate you but you
can't restructure society and not
replace it with anything like they don't
have an answer it's like so how many
genders are there well I don't know well
how many can we put in a driver's
license well I don't know well how many
pronouns do I have to learn well I don't
know whatever someone wants well that's
stupid cuz now you got to go to each
individual person and and preface
everything with what's your pronoun yeah
instead of just hey head what's your
name you know a guy what's your name
it's it's way too much and you know
Society has has has villainized anybody
that
doesn't if you don't sway with the with
the alphabet Community you going to
catch the you going to catch the Wrath
you know if you if if it's if it's C
well look what happen with Dave
Chappelle when they came after him and
then he doubled down which you know made
him a hero basically yeah and he was
independent enough and independently
wealthy enough to where you can't stop
my money
that's the thing if you're attached to
anything where they can cut you off
that's the that's the power they have
over yeah but if you're independent of
that if you can't take my bread away
know you get a little more freedom and a
little more leway to kind of operate
like that
yeah well he yeah he experienced that
that was you know that was kind of new
right where the lgbtq like they came for
oh yeah they came for like a black
celebrity and and a big celebrity yeah
and a big one at that but he had people
he had people standing up for him oh of
course yeah and he had he had alphabet
Community people standing up
there trying to you trying to you trying
to impose way too much upon people oh
yeah you know uh when you when you abuse
or mistreat somebody that's one thing
but things that people don't know or
don't understand you have to get people
room to to grow to that understanding
and even if they never do understand you
got to find a common ground to where you
can at least get along yeah yeah oh no
yeah a lot of people don't realize
realiz that they don't like my my
booking age he's a gay Cuban and he's
the you would think if you didn't know
like super gay the most homophobic
you've ever met in your
life just because he'll be like these
trans people are out of there I watchh
him I swear to you we were at a
steakhouse right here and uh he's gay
he's there with his like boyfriend he
he's against gay marriage and he's gay
but it's just really he's like he's like
I just I just don't understand like we
I'm just gay why don't I want to get
married it's like the it's just they're
pissing me off like William you can't
say that he's like no you can't say that
only I can say that but he was sitting
there he had two drinks in and the
server was white woman she goes uh I
don't really understand the whole like
the new gender queer like pansexual and
she's asking him cuz he's gay so she
thinks he knows and he's gay Cuban guy
and he just looks at he goes they're all
murderers I'm like who William like I'm
just telling you having lived in these
used to be drag queens were funny we did
drag queen shows he like we weren't
doing it in libraries with children like
this is gone way too far and he loses
his mind he loses mind not all gay and
lesbian people are on board with all of
this that's the thing too they're not
represented right it's never absolute
it's never absolute but the Lou the
squeaky will get to all so you know if
you get enough enough loud ones that are
on that side they kind of drying out the
ones that are you know a little more
sensible or a little more uh amenable to
to other people's
ideas yeah you would think it's one of
those things where um there's a real
disconnect like kind of like you were
talking about military like people who
are you know people with pens versus
people with guns there's a real
disconnect between Elites and power and
the average American citizen oh does
huge disc yeah you put a bridge between
that you put a you put a whole Bridge up
sorry I can't hear I got the ra what was
it I saying I didn't hear you I saying
there's a real difference between the
Elites in power and the average American
citizen abs like they trying to make it
seem like either you know it's like root
roots with gay dudes or you're Pro LGB
it's like no hold there's a middle
ground where a lot of people like no do
whatever you want that's fine but you
can't just say they're Limitless genders
and then in Canada they'll find you for
hate speech if you use the wrong
pronouns yeah wow oh yeah I have a
friend you know this is why I come from
backgound as as a comic a friend in
Canada who was fined for a joke for a
joke for a joke yeah so the freedom of
so the freedom of speech doesn't extend
to Canada the same way it does here no
not at all and it wasn't even like it
wasn't even a racist joke or not that
that would make it acceptable it wasn't
racist it wasn't sexist it wasn't
homophobic it was a joke about a from a
makeawish foundation who uh he was like
on their version of American Idol and uh
what happened is you know everyone
supported this kid so I'm butchering the
joke cuz I don't remember it but he
literally got fined put before human
rights tribunal his joke was like okay
we all supported this kid we all wanted
him to be on Canadian Idol and the kid
was awful right but it was like a makea
wish thing he's like and so we did it we
supported it we voted for him but now
this has gone on 5 years and he just
like he still won't die right that was
but it turns out the kid's mom lied
about what he had later on wow so like
that girl that girl that was that was
that way to get in like the girl that
the the girl that her mom Munch proxy
thing yeah yeah yeah it's called like
Munch by proxy she Rose Blancher yeah
yeah that Gypsy the gypsy girl oh yeah
yeah he was fine for that joke and the
mom was like this caused unbelief they
had people donating so much stuff man
they was like they was making money they
a't over fit yeah it's um I didn't know
Canada that that's inter I didn't know
Canada didn't have that level of Freedom
oh no country outside of the US does
there's not a country that has freedom
of speech in shrin of the and of course
it's limited here now too like it's not
that's the problem we really don't have
consequences you can say what you want
with the consequences that come with can
you deal with that no I don't even think
you can say what you want anymore like
when you actually have the government
you know telling Spotify to take off Joe
Rogan like that's to me that's pretty
corrupt like that's you're not even free
to say what you want anymore if it's the
wrong opinion level sensorship yeah
exactly it's where the line blurs
between what you want and what hurts
somebody else right like and there's a
there's a responsibility in in the
person that's saying something to to be
able to you know be cognizant of yeah
how how what you saying has an impact
perod oh wow look at that yeah I get it
way better way cleaner I look less
homeless nice thank you man appreciate
it but you don't have the freedom of
spee like you say you got to deal with
the cons right
after when did the world become so damn
sensitive got a different level of of of
playing right right everybody finds a
different level of what's playful to
some people playful is I'm just going
I'mma walk behind you and I'mma kick you
know kick kick your feet and make you
trip over yourself ha that's playful and
to another dude like white Howard made
playfulness trying to you know playfully
grab your genitals some dudes don't play
like that and every everybody don't
don't play the same I don't think they I
think I think those are sex offenders I
don't think that's everybody don't play
oh this is the old grab my balls games I
mean play the game I guess the
house no but the problem like you use
Dave Chappel is an example okay it's one
thing you don't like what he says right
don't go see him it's another thing when
you're trying to tell venues that they
can't host him when other people want to
see him right like he's I mean he's one
of the well and then to of that you got
a fact the whole Foundation is that his
art form is based
in being just that yeah like that's that
is his art form you now you're trying to
tell him he can't practice his art yeah
that is his is going to the LED yeah
exactly going to the edge that's that's
exactly what the r form is yeah that's
what comedy
is getting up yeah no that's that was
really uh one of those issues like he
lost some venues and it's just think
about it's just absolutely oh here I
guess I'll sit here it crazy but there
aren't many people who could here's the
thing for every Dave Chappelle you see
right who's able to do it like you said
cuz he's independent there's 20 30 200
more who are just getting started yeah
and they get absolutely shut down where
they can never build a career because
someone says no no you said that right
you're not allowed to be at the party I
mean look look at look at Kevin hard and
Oscars yeah cuz he made a gay joke eight
years
ago yeah I
know well I guess they really showed
him
he's like the richest comedian on earth
now that guy is all constantly working
my God I don't know how that guy is
walking upright at money allowed him to
save
himself how many times did Cat Williams
get arrested was it like 400 times in 82
months hey he
said he said arrest but no conviction
I've been arrested many times but I've
never you ain't never seen a
mother oh this doing a cat
Williams over here thinking he's only
one got to keep your pimp hand strong
mother never been convicted shaving that
man's head with my bent back paperclips
and
shitu he said he never been in court
isn't he coming to uh
wi yeah
yeah remember that video of him getting
choked out by a
14-year-old that playing oh my God that
was play soccer he playing soccer about
12y old I know that was tough a man
boy he said he said it was a man
boy that was tough to watch though man I
felt bad for him you're like this guy
must be having a rough time if he's
getting choked out by a
12-year-old I mean you've had to make
some bad decisions to end up in that
position right there like abely to ask
some questions but no they went at they
went after him a
lot he s his he lost the his
opportunity Kevin Hart got the turn that
was actually he yeah it was his time to
be that guy yeah because of the trouble
Kevin Hart was able to step in and take
all of those opportunities for lay him
into what he is now but he did it to
himself so yeah know he's done well for
himself but you said Kevin Hart make
money hand
over I mean could you imagine if like
PRI were coming up today can you imagine
like there's no that guy would that guy
would get in trouble immediately he said
he's the best my conversation would be
he wouldn't be able to tell the same
level of J M up it wouldn't be rich
would for R I know it wouldn't be
Richard but you know Eddie Murphy
wouldn't be Eddie Murphy if not for
Richard Pride da Chappelle wouldn't be
but as far as R is the one yeah yeah
yeah no I know I know but you can't
offend any
problem like some voices probably should
be like I ain't going to say shut down
but like some stuff you just really
don't want to hear like I don't never
want to hear sexy red again hear what
sexy red you ever heard of sexy red
who's sexy red do
homework waste about waste about 15
minutes of your time and do your
homework sexy red he's a she's a young
rapper oh no no I do know sex I was
still thinking of comedians there a
comedian he was saying red fox I was
like is this like a new Red Fox sexy red
everybody's Freedom don't need to be
free yeah that's just it everybody's
Freedom don't need to be free well they
can say it but the problem is I yeah
like the problem is you have people who
amplify like the people who try and
suppress a voice like Chappelle then
they amplify a voice like whatever is it
could be sexy red or you know cardi B
whatever it is we're like oh no this is
I mean the fat pride thing is a big
thing now too you're like we have a
health from in America and now we're
like no no you can't say doctors are not
allowed to say you're obese you don't
want you don't want a body shame youmore
you want a body shame yeah which I don't
even what was that turn body shame that
was invented by fat white women in like
18 that's real talk she lost an argument
with her husband and she was about to be
checkmated she was like are you body
shaving me that's real talk right there
that's what that Canyon from once again
if somebody's able to attach a level
of offensiveness to any any conversation
that you have they put you in Peril of
being ostracized and alen Las oh I got
sued by one of those fat
models yeah cuz the problem is she was
out there saying like this is healthy I
said no your blood type's pudding
like that's not
healthy and she she said it caused her
irreparable damage mentally I'm like sh
no what's causing a reparable damage is
your liver right now trying to keep up
with the enzymes that are flowing
through your like sh this it's one thing
to be overweight right we all agree
don't just beat the out us or make fun
of someone because they're struggling
with their weight it's another thing to
tell everyone no no you have to say that
everybody is beautiful and healthy
that's a lie that's the problem the
problem is the LIE yeah people attach so
much of their own feeling to what
everybody else is supposed to that's I
think I think that's what you know and
once again for anybody that's obese or
whatever if that's truly how you feel as
long as nobody's exacting any punishment
upon you they should be able to feel how
they feel yeah about that now I don't
have the right to uh insult you or or
bad to you over that but I also don't
have to go along with you saying that
this is healthy and this is you know
that's your that if that's your measure
of beauty so be chubby chasers you can't
put that upon anybody else yeah but now
the problem is yeah I mean we have like
it's it's also a problem too when you're
paying right your taxes pay for
healthcare like we have a strained
system you know so and this is not a new
thing okay you you know you'll hear
women often say like oh you don't have
to deal with the unrealistic uh beauty
standards you know men only women I hold
on a second name me one fat Pride male
model one
and they well they go they go oh uh
Chris Farley they go I go these were
comedians they were hilarious they
weren't considered sexy they had to be
talented like no one said so I actually
here in Dallas when I was starting up I
opened up for Bruce Bruce do he you guys
know him Bruce it was Bruce Bruce black
boy with two eyes and me want to talk
about eating on stage 19-year-old
white me opening up for black boy and
Bruce Bruce but that guy was I mean that
guy was hugee and he would joke about it
and it's like no one's going to go up
and make fun of him for being fat but
he's also not saying I'm a sex symbol
right like it's two different things
that's the issue exactly exactly Bru did
say I used to knock him down with that
boy granddaddy can I have that oh my god
dude I used to piss myself
laughing help granddaddy get out the
tub granddaddy can I have that boy you
knock him
down yeah it was uh it was it was a it
was an experience experience man it was
a trip like I won it was back in Myspace
I won a MySpace comedy contest and the
the prize was to open how that that's
how you got to open that one yeah and
they were like you get to open for Bruce
Spruce and I was like oh and they're
like you have to pay for your plane
ticket and I was like well I don't have
like usually I get paid to open up for
somebody but I wanted to cuz like a big
audience at that time absolutely and uh
I didn't know he came out with like an
Entourage like he was a fighter you ever
seen him live yeah I saw him at the impr
in Addison yeah yeah so you know like he
has like the lights and he come out with
like his whole crew and he walks out
slowly so I was like you know that's not
something I was like hey Bruce Bruce and
then he's nowhere and the music starts
I'm like hey Bruce Bruce ladies and
gentlemen and then he comes out of the
back room he just looks at me and he
starts walking up slowly and I'm like
hey keep it going Bruce Bruce Bruce
Bruce and I remember standing on stage I
had no idea he was going to do it um and
boy when he got to that stage you could
hear like it was like it was like
thunder people love that man he's one of
the few comedians I've seen he was funny
from the very beginning yeah the whole
entire time until he left he was funed
the whole time A lot of times you'll get
a l in in that in a set yeah he was
funny the whole time did you see him you
Ain see him when he hosted uh when he uh
hosted death Comedy Jam when they tap to
New Orleans that was uh that was uh I
may have seen that that wasn't death
Comedy Jam that was uh the one that was
on BET well which one was that there was
I went to the tap too I went to the tap
too yeah I was in New Orleans in my
cousin was at com comic VI
comic at the or theater y yep so we was
there at the same
time do comedy yeah yeah I don't go on
the road as much I mean doing the show
every day so it's kind of like it's
comedy but it's not standup comedy but
uh yeah you film this you do some of
this every you do this every day so I'm
usually in the studio every day like you
know doing stuff so it's it's it's kind
of like a middle ground between like a
late night show and um I guess sort of
podcast it's a hybrid but then we do
this stuff on location and it's a mix
where a big part of this honestly is you
know I was I was in also traditional
media for a long time so like I'd be on
Fox News and CNN and all these different
places and what you saw that changed my
mind thing it started I pitched that to
all the networks and they said no one's
going to want to sit and watch just like
two normal people talk for an hour and
not be edited and I said well we're
sitting here talking and you guys give
us four minutes and you you want us to
hit talking points like there's nothing
productive I said I think people will
watch it and they said absolutely not so
I went and did it and it worked turns
out people wanted to see real
interactions and once you get out of the
media bubble you realize that most
people share a lot more in common than
they have that's different and it's just
it's a it's a house of cards and I think
you had a had a good idea because you
know on the four minute
segment you're you're hitting the
surface with people right you give
somebody 11 minutes 18 minutes then you
really start hearing how they feel with
yeah that's what I got from you talk to
those people and uh I said the lady mad
she was she stood out to me because I
remember you telling her look we've been
talking almost 30 minutes you could tell
she was really speaking cuz at first it
was cool she was kind of surface level
with it I think this I but by the time
y'all got going she was like well look I
don't believe you can really get you
really get an opportunity to hear how
people actually feel yeah you know
people going to give you their
representative first then you get to
be yeah the problem that you're into if
I'm remembering Madison as the right
person is culturally like white women if
they yell and they shout at you they
think they win cuz a lot of a lot of
like dudes like okay they get brow
beaten like all right I don't want to
upset her because they don't want to be
accused of being sexist or you know um
oh absolutely you know as a black man I
totally understand the last thing you
want to be somewh publicly with a white
woman as a white guy too so so you
definitely don't want you don't want to
be on the wrong end of that well cuz
it's like if you see a black woman
yelling at a black man or even a white
man you're like oh he probably said some
like he probably did something but
if it's a white woman she's like
screaming
rape yeah
no I mean that's the real problem too
you know that's the nature of what we do
we we we're conditioned to to to just
react to stuff instantly
yeah yeah a lot of that lot of that
condition in comes to environments we
were raed in or you know stuff that we
you know brought in as entertainment
yeah throughout our lives or whatever or
just you know like I said just what
whatever factors that created the
environment we were in growing up I know
I know and it's like if you just say
let's say there's a let's say there's a
mass shooting or whatever it is a
tragedy and if you just say hey hold on
let's just wait a minute for some
information right they go what you don't
care about the Dead uh dead kids like no
no I do I'm just saying when have we
ever made good decisions without just
waiting just reacting immediately you
never make good decisions that way right
but we're conditioned like you're saying
just react yeah you need a new click you
need a new
reel part of Canada are you from so I
was raised in Montreal have you spent
any time in Canada never been man that's
somewhere I like to visit I've never
been to
don't don't it's a stupid place man I
heard Toronto was nice was nice okay
have you guys seen our prime minister no
I don't even know who the prime minister
in T is have have you guys do you guys
not know like not just do blackface do
have you seen this you said what the
prime Min the prime minister of Canada
has not only done blackface he's done it
like 15 times damn really he don't give
a no I no no he just like it's just cuz
he has the right of paint like he would
go to sports games and paint his arms
and legs black oh you went went all the
way yeah yeah yeah yeah and he but now
he says like oh I support the lesbian
gay bisexual transgender two-spirited
Community he's just Mr you know
Progressive so everyone's like oh that's
fine you did blackace like like so many
times oh he's a piece of oh my gosh
Justin Trudeau is the biggest piece of
in the Canada has a lot of beauty but
like i' never I've never pay attention
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah okay here we go
do we have it this is the prime minister
this is the worst one I'll show what is
he doing that's well he's doing exactly
what you think he's doing but think he
better not be
doing
oh oh wow oh yeah that's just
one oh yeah
yeah like he was at a football game oh
he putain he's actually trying to
imitate the black man oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah so okay here's a perfect example
like context over content we were doing
a show live uh at U ofm so it's a big
theater like5 200 people and um and you
know it's right on the border of Canada
and so this guy's done blackface like 15
times right but a lot of people don't
know it so you need to raise awareness
so what we did was we said hey we have
some guests here and we had celebrities
we said and we have the prime minister
of Canada in the audience and was just a
dude in horrible black
face and people like what's that and
then we show the clip so the joke is not
blackface the joke is the prime minister
is in
blackface and uh that's the kind of
thing where people could say well hold
on a second you're doing blackface no no
we're mocking the guy who you just saw
doing blackface because people should
know that absolutely yeah but
sometimes the joke becomes more
offensive than the fact that's why you
have that de Chappelle man oh yeah that
guy yeah that that wasn't cool at all no
like I said when you said the black face
I said and then you said sporting events
I said okay well maybe he's out there
like the football guy with the half
black face no he's actually he's
actually imitating the black dude black
dude okay that ain't cool at all no it's
not his legs and everything yeah with
the F with the FR wig on yeah I mean
yeah yeah yeah he was doing too much he
put a banana down his pants too for one
of
them yeah and and the Canadians elected
this guy well here's the thing right so
I'm like obviously like more
conservative leaning but since he calls
himself Mr Progressive now they forgive
him they go oh it's fine but like Megan
Kelly we were just talk Megan Kelly you
know why she got fired from her job when
they were talking about blackface it was
a conversation so you see that guy's the
prime minister of Canada and they say oh
it's okay Megan Kelly said well I think
there there's an important difference
between like blackface or like when I
was young you know Diana Ross was really
popular so like my friend who was white
dressed up like Diana Ross with the big
wig for Halloween like that's not racist
it fired her oh W like I I mean you can
disagree but I agree with her that if a
little girl loves Diana Ross that's not
racist she just loves Diana Ross and uh
she got fired for that but this guy
still has his job as prime minister of a
country that's wild think about that
align like said once you align yourself
with the alab yeah you you get you going
to those numbers and because they're not
the ones being uh Shan to Shane they're
willing to overlook that aspect and be
like well yeah like you said that's yeah
that's cool now had he made a
transgender joke or he showed up as a
transgender then it would have been a
problem right well it's just I don't
know it just doesn't it seem like
sometimes they're just they're using
these different groups like I will tell
you this like a lot of politicians I I
watch it and I go they're using the
trans they're using the black community
the black community when it's convenient
they go oh you know they go out they say
black lives matter they do that and then
what do they do is they go back to
redlining or they don't do for the black
community but they say the right
words cam out it's perpect for you you
know yeah if your group is what I need
at this moment I can do and say some
things that guarant your favor for that
moment yeah and then once I've gotten
what I need now I can go back to what I
risen with this tending to d right go
back to that yeah that that's how black
tend to get oh yeah oh yeah some some
some when I and when I say blacks I mean
just as a whole I don't mean individual
no of course not but but you do have
some like in everything else you do have
some that are working towards like the
right stuff but they just get
overshadowed by so much of the
that you don't really get to hear about
them well that's one thing that I
definitely like as there are certain
things that first off I think a lot of
the idea that people think it's white
privilege it's and if you want
to ask me about it I can tell you but
there are certain things like for
example young black boys I had a good
friend who was black and he loved metal
so he was like really into Slayer and
Iron Maiden and I watched his black
friends tell him like are you doing
you can't listen you got and they you
know told him me you need to listen to
hip-hop and he just got on it's
like this kid just liked he liked metal
he was a comic book nerd that's one
thing we don't really have as white now
we don't have the community that black
people have that is like this which is
really productive but we also don't have
those expectations like hey you're a
black you're a black man you shouldn't
be listening to Iron Maiden and that's
got to be tough that's got to be tough
to deal with like that's something that
we don't have burdened on us as as white
people the level the expectation of what
you are to be black you know what I mean
sometimes like like you're talking about
where they'll like you're saying if
someone's trying to do good work
sometimes they'll say like well you're
not really you're not really black
you're a black enough right how many
times do we hear that it's like exactly
well who gets to say that
exactly that's correct you're not never
thought about it from a white person sup
met it but that does come with being
black yeah Essences and spaces the
expectation of how you are to conduct
yourself expectations of you are kind of
laid out for you yeah you know what I'm
saying where a lot of times when you do
choose to be free you know what you are
you're going to be ostracized in a lot
of places like why is you doing that
yeah I did
it for black male right tell me if I'm
wrong anytime you go somewhere right and
you're the minority automatically have
to make yourself less threatening
Absolut oh yeah it's inate it's innate
that whenever you you have to make
yourself less threatened because people
view you as I think some sometimes yeah
I think sometimes that's true for sure
brother multiple countries whever I've
been is that what I you have to connect
yourself that's threat well I don't know
if it's like that way in
Uganda
I think they probably moreat the countri
that I've been to you have to make
yourself less threatened and then once
you accepted like in care you know once
I once you accepted oh yeah then you're
good yeah you're good but you got to you
got to be accepted you that's different
I mean think about it you brought up you
brought up Ukraine right right Remember
When The War first broke out yeah
Ukraine when the afans were trying to
get on the train to get out to escape
what was happening well they were pushed
out they couldn't get on the train you
know what I'm saying so wherever we go
it's it's it is a is work that we have
to do yeah to make ourselves acceptable
so let me this is when I was talking
with with them back there so if you have
to like in
2023 uh in
America who do you think like do you
think that people are in even playing
field and everyone has their own
different struggles or hurdles to
overcome or do you think that I it feels
different not even yeah so who do you
think has the easiest here's the
difference right I'll give you I'll give
you an example my daughter went to LSU
yeah
right and was doing well at L but wasn't
getting the support from the professors
that she thought she need so you know
what she did she transferred from LSU
went right across town to HBCU Souther
University and she feels like she at
home yeah cuz she at school and teachers
and people that look like her and care
about
that's the way they make her feel there
she didn't feel that way H
Sho but does she know that they didn't
treat her they treat her that way
because she was black it just it's just
it's just being for here's another
example right I went to the bou Classic
this weekend I used to go to LSU games
all the time right went to the body go
to L Sho games great great atmosphere
everything's good great game team people
F yeah but when you go to a son Universe
at HBCU game it's totally different how
you how you feel how you act when I'm
out there with my people say people that
look like me I mean I just had a that
was the best time I had was this B CL in
a long time at a sport well there are
plenty of people who look like you on
the field I got that but not in the same
at LSU game but Southern game everybody
on the field everybody in the stand the
media the everybody everybody the
parking line everybody but I will say I
was surprised to find cuz I I grew up
under the misconception growing up in
Bat RS with you know the Divide between
Southern and LSU I grew up with what up
what up Grant I'll be with you in just a
second um I grew up the misconception
that LSU you know when you go to LSU it
was going that was always going to be
racist cuz you know grow up with that
misconception of baton rge like you got
that side of town they fooled us used to
be like that it's not like that now it
still is in certain parts depends on
where you go but that's another discuss
yeah uh but when I first went to a LSU
football game as a kid and was working
working the parking lots scared out of
my mind cuz I'm like yeah I don't know
if they going to you know somebody going
to do something to me and then man these
people was just so nice like hey come
grab some uh we got some food over here
it's just love like you know what I'm
saying but every environment ain't like
that we is a different state that's the
right every environment they like that
was just LSU that was just the LSU game
yeah you know know what I'm saying cuz
you them same people put them in a
different environment they treat you
totally different and I've run across
some of the same people from them same
games in different environments and they
they they it's like they flip the switch
like get away from me
let me post the thought real quick
so the headline is um we as black people
are always standing now follow up with
that by saying I'm from New York
originally I travel the world you know
and live in many places in this country
so everywhere you go there's a Jewish
Community robust there's a Mexican
Community robust meaning they all stick
together but when you go to our
community what you see you know
everywhere I went with there MLK is
tarnished because of the crime like us
not allow the crabs in bar Barrel thing
us not allowing each other to succeed
why is that from your perspective or
everybody's in your perspective well I
guess the qu yeah the why right and the
problem is you and I appreciate that
you're able to ask it because guess what
if I ever answer that even as far as an
opinion where I say this is what I think
it's racist right so white people don't
want to answer that question because
they don't want to be accused of being
racist well what do you do when so many
of your representatives are white people
right where they go no no I need to
check my privilege and not answer I can
tell you uh for example where I'm from
in Detroit I can tell you why that's the
case in Detroit it's not the same in
every city but if you go back to Lynden
Johnson in the model cities uh program
you know he said I'll have those n-words
voting Democrat for the next 60 years um
Detroit people don't know this cuz my
dad grew up in Detroit his home that he
grew up as a child just sold for $88,000
like a 22t home for $88,000 right he
lived in downtown Detroit he watched
tanks go down his road for the Detroit
Riots um and what happened it was the
wealthiest city in the country in the
1950s for all people white black it was
the Paris of the Midwest then they said
you know what we're going to come in
we're going to centrally Urban plan this
city was the model cities program right
where they put a bunch of money into it
because they wanted to take credit for
successful City that came with modern
sort of welfare systems benefits but it
also came with strings attached what
happened Detroit went from the
wealthiest city in the country to an
absolute war zone the government came in
engineered it and screwed that whole
place up so typically speaking my answer
is whether you're white whether you're
black whether you're Latino whether
you're LGBT like when the government
says hey we're going to fix this it
usually makes it worse that's a big
problem and it does go back to Lynden
Johnson and the idea of and they said
they were going to buy black votes that
was a big part of it oh yeah oh yeah I
get it all the time yeah which I mean I
think now we're separated where people
are able to have different opinions and
it's pretty good but let me ask you this
because you said you think okay so the
playing field is not even and I think
that that's true in some ways certainly
like culturally I don't know that I
believe in like systemic racism in the
government that's just but why do you
think this is something that always I
it's just a curious question to me why
do you think suicide in this country is
exclusively a white male problem 70% of
suicides in the United States are white
men white men are they're twice as
likely as black men to kill themselves
I I can I can tell you I can tell you a
little bit from personal experience but
a lot from
just black people we consider just in
general taking yourself out it's a
non-negotiation right like you was just
brought up like you ain't going to you
you ain't going to take yourself out
first of all God ain't going to forgive
you for that I think it's big it's it's
a huge thing it's a huge thing yeah God
ain't going to forgive you for that and
then secondly it's just a you know it's
it's been taught as a cowardly way out
yeah you know what I'm saying in a lot
of circumstances so it's like
but you know some people like there's
always outliers yeah you know what I'm
saying but that wouldn't account for two
times the
rate and I think I think one thing that
definitely that I we were talking about
this like this is why we we do this and
talk like in in in groups and places
like this the one thing that white men a
lot of white men la in 2023 is community
is what community community so like this
is for example like I was just talking
with um with Maya and Jasmine about this
where she was talking about single
parent households she said you know and
sometimes it's a deadbeat you know Dad
who doesn't want to be around she said
but sometimes it's true you have a mom
who doesn't want him around you know he
wants to support his kids but she wants
to take the money for herself so she was
very balanced in the white Community if
your marriage fails or um you know you
get fired you don't have camaraderie or
people like hey man you get the next one
or hey I'm here for it you're shamed
right away and so white men typically
they just isolate themselves and that's
the biggest contributing factor to Su
suicide is do you have a good social
support network and that's that was the
the the thing
is the experience of historically being
black in this country you've had to
you've had to recognize strength in your
people right right so that amount of
strength is not going to allow you to
get to the point where you say I'm just
going to take myself out of
in general and so that's that that will
make up for that two times R and with
the faith thing added into it oh yeah
faith is a huge thing that's a big
reason obviously in the black it's still
like it's not offensive to instill faith
in your kids yeah where yeah right now
in the white but still you have to think
like the isolation that's a I know that
uh you know especially if you're telling
like if you're telling a white man and I
say this because this is taught in
universities check your privilege you
don't know struggle and then your
marriage fails you lose your job you're
like well I just must be a screw up
because I have every Advantage right we
don't have anything tough going on for
us and if you tune in to the media and
it says like yeah what are you bitching
about you literally have people right
saying like white tears which not saying
everyone but I'm saying I know from
experience having had suicide especially
coming from you know military family and
friends where a lot of them take
themselves out because they feel lonely
you don't have this typically where like
white men go and they're comfortable
just being themselves around people
there's no community and so they take
themselves out and it's a it's a real
problem especially since Co
suicide there's are more white Nows than
our black Nows too so right no I mean
even as a percentage it's crazy high and
it's like you're twice as likely just to
take your own life and yeah I think I
think a lot of that has to go with come
with distance traveled as well you know
most black people and I'm not saying all
because there's always you know levels
to it but most black people we Face
struggles throughout our lives so when
struggle and hard times hit the
adversity
uh doesn't affect in the same manner as
somebody that's had much less adversity
you know you grow up poor inner city uh
less than you lose a job that's
just another you know it's just another
time yeah but if your life has been
somewhat privileged maybe not topof the
line but middle class or whatever and
you hit those hard times
where have you been trained to deal with
that adversity so when the adversity
adversity hitting you at 27 28 years old
and you've never had adversity it's
going to hit a whole lot harder than
somebody that grew up struggle that grew
up with a strugg they're not going to
panic they're not going to you know
they're not going to look for the end
game or the end way out because they
going to look at it like well no it
just it's just another time I got to get
back up and dust myself off whereas if
I've been bred to be a success and I've
taught that success is all I'm about
when I do fail I'm going to take it a
lot harder because now talked about the
expectations of the black person now
what you sound like you're saying is the
white man has expectations you're
supposed to be successful you're
supposed to do this you're supposed to
do that and when you don't do those
things now you in your mind you're
taking it as I'm a total and complete
up so why why do I need to stay
here whereas a black dude going to look
at it it's just
Wednesday
I think there's I think there's some I
mean it wouldn't account for like you
were saying because there're more white
people but as a percentage in other
words there's more poor white people too
so the percentage still they're still in
any social class so even in other words
a poor white person or a rich white
person is still twice as likely
generally to commit suicide as a poor or
Rich black person a lot of white people
have adversity just like they're black
absolutely but they're still more likely
to kill themselves no matter what white
people never highlight those white white
people want don't highlight poor white
people white people highlight white
people that are doing well the outliers
the the trailer park white people the
people that are on the welfare white
people never highlight those people
they're not they don't get put on
magazine they don't get put into the ass
they just brush to the side with the
rest of the comment so white people that
are less than they're left to kind of
pend for themselves so I I believe they
they face adversity like we do and they
but you know what white people probably
figur that once again it's a Wednesday
for them we had already now they still
May kill themselves cuz the black people
do kill themselves just at a different
rate yeah at a much lower rate but the
but the poor white boy don't feel the
same way as the white boy that went to
St Marx or the green his life haven't
been the same so he not so if his lights
go off he just going to find him a
candle or open the window the rich white
guy his lights go off he's thinking damn
you know how did I wind up at this point
where I'm feeling like this I mean
economics and your your social social
upbringing I think has a lot to do with
I can only speak for the black people
the faith part does pay a big part a
part but that plays a huge part with the
black people cuz my grandfather was a
Baptist minister so and suicide is one
of those things that you just don't even
contemplate right yeah because once
again like they said God not going to
forgive you for that and if black people
if we haven't had anything we've had a
heavy dose of God so we understand well
I can't do that cuz I'm not going to get
into heaven so
we you know that's usually that's going
to be one of your last last options but
I guess in other words if you could you
know there there's the old uh story or
the allegory of you know everyone wrote
their problem down on a piece of paper
they put it into a hat and they could
pick any problem that they want out of
the hat right and invariably they picked
out their own problem yeah because they
knew how to deal with it so I guess the
question would be if we all I think what
we're agreeing on is like God faith is
way stronger in the black community and
and community in general right there's a
stronger sense of community um black
Comm would you rather if we accept the
premise right just assuming here that
okay there's this white privilege as far
as let's say wealth or starting point
would you take that over having the
faith and the strength of community that
you have would you take that as a
greater would you take what white people
have as a leg up as a greater privilege
or the values of family and God and
children what's what's worth more the
family and God and because that's how I
was raised so that's that's what what
I'm going to stick with but I'm not
going to lie I peek at that other side
don't be like well I you know if
you mean to tell me I'm going to get a
you know get get pushed to the head of
the line in a lot of instances start
from a farther up place that's that is
appealing to you but because i' I've
been so deeply entrenched on what I came
from that's all I know I'm going to go
with the familiar like you said I'm
going to pick my own problem out there
saying this point pick your own blessing
right pick your own blessing like
raising a wealthy family or raising a
family that values God and community
if that wealthy family not going to be
filled with love and faith I don't want
that I rather come from where I came
ugly things happen in pretty houses man
I if I couldn't if I couldn't get the
good family with your bre I rather just
going fight for my own Survival and and
make my own fortune then then start from
a place of wealth with with with with a
Detachment yeah from the faith and and
and the family yeah cuz that's not the
big differentiating factor when you look
at it you see you see people who are
miserable who have have money you kill
themselves who have money you said both
black and white the most important thing
you see invariably is like relationships
that matter absolutely money is nothing
but more than a two money all money does
is means you don't have money problems
that don't mean you don't have problems
so a poor guy and a rich guy both G have
problem the rich guy just not going to
be worried about where he going to get
the $200 from poor guy is goingon to
have that but the problem you going to
have problems
regardless yeah I I would rather have an
attachment to a community and a family
with a faith and an opportunity to give
me some money to have bread and then
kind of be somewhat detached and no I
wouldn't want that yeah well I'm
concerned though too cuz now you see it
like this will hit all communities
people are more uh disconnected than
ever with social media I mean man you
even see with black or white younger
Generations they don't interact with
people as much they don't have
relationships so if you think of what we
see with where suicide is highest and
it's in people who are isolated every
one of all racial groups they're all
isolating themselves now looking at a
screen that I I don't know when the
Stats come in but I don't think it goes
well in 20 years man what the world will
be I have the slightest idea because
like what you said is people it's too
easy for a person to isolate themselves
yeah it's much much easier for you to
stand outside and just watch your phone
then truly interact you know we because
we work in a barber
shop this is not forced interaction but
this is uh abnormal and and yeah this
this is an out people come in here
looking for the intera but this isn't
the norm no you have a generation where
most of them don't go to church fewer of
them than ever are playing sports you
know what I mean so you think about that
they're I mean it's like it's it's like
40% depending on the stat you use of
like young men who aren't interested in
even dating women because they're afraid
of being falsely accused or now they
have porn on the Internet so they don't
even care anymore it's like well like
where are you going to get that
interaction cuz that's pivotal as human
beings and we see it all the time
because uh
the younger Generations as they grow up
now their interaction skills are very
poor they don't really know how to hold
a
conversation with someone you know male
to male male to female female to female
a lot of time they don't know how
because it's much easier for them to
express themselves digitally than it is
for me to actually sit down and engage
we see them in here they'll be sitting
chairs apart and they'll text text back
and forth rather than just have a
communicate I know they'll Tex back and
forth and that's not going to be good
for you so here's a picture of my look
at
her right there exactly exactly it's
just this is what Society is pushing us
and if you don't force and make your
children uh a part of a community
they'll grow that way yeah well that's
why you were talking about to bring it
back to like the lgbtqa a i plus that's
the actual acronym they use
now yes lesbian gay by seual
transgender the whole alphabet pansexual
and they use a twice I mean they hijack
the whole alphabet yeah yeah but a lot
now you have it's over 20% of young
people identify as part of that but why
do you think because they're getting
this stuff it's flooding them inating
them with it they inating them with it
man I'm sorry you know I'm an older you
know I'm an older person I'm you know in
my 50s now and I can go back to when you
know all black guys in your 50s look
younger than me she you got from
Louisiana you didn't you didn't you know
if a person was if you weren gay you
definitely wasn't gay at 10 and 11 years
old right you know if you wound up being
an adult that was gay or either you HD
it extremely wa until you became but
like you said if you're going to
inundate kids with that with that
message and not only the message but let
them know that it's okay don't let
anybody tell you you can't be this or
you you get to choose to be these things
you're giving them options oh yeah you I
grew up it's boys and girls that's it
yeah it's boys and this girls but as we
progressed in time and Society society
says you can't tell your kids that they
have to identify as that well I told my
kids that they had that and that's just
how that's well that goes back to family
and Faith that's just how that's going
roll yeah but when you open up and give
children option you're doing way more
than what they need be allowed to do
because a child's mind is there to be
shaped and molded it's going to be
shaped and molded by what you give them
the opportunity to we grew up in a time
where you know you couldn't watch that
movie you ain't old enough to watch that
you can't listen to that music you don't
need to be hearing that but if you just
let them have everything and you give
them the option to be whatever they want
well you taking your chances on the
wrong thing sticky no you're absolutely
right yes only thing with me
Mike with that
is I got a ton
of man don't no
problem but what gets to me is this when
somebody comes and tells
me that God made
mistake that gets me right there cuz
then I set them down right I said let me
ask you this question say hello God's
perfect right I say yeah I said God
mistakes right right they said yes I'm
saying
he's say yeah so tell me how you made a
mistake when you you mean that they're
gay yeah tell me how I me you don't know
it's a
[Music]
choice did yall know that King James was
kinging I've read that yeah I don't know
that's been
confirmed King James
thanks
man
leing about
LeBron talking about the
new yeah it is it's a but that's a real
thing like you can have these
conversations here I'll tell you like in
the white Community you just like Dave
Chappelle experience what white men have
been experiencing for a very long time
where it's like you are not allowed to
have an opinion white women go apeshit
if they're liberal and they're like I
can't you're you're homophobic you're
transphobic so most guys they just they
just don't say anything that's a rough
way to exist too man you know yeah I I
mean I've always worked in a black
barber shop so I I really don't have uh
a level of perspective I'd like to know
what a white barers shop is what the
conversations are like on a day-to-day
basis cuz
realistically the talk we have here this
might just just be a random Tuesday if
the right top comes up we just we'll
just come across this and everybody will
chime in but I would hate to
be in a in a in
a a group or category of people where
there's no like you said the sense of
community know the barers shop this is
the last place a black man can be all
the way black you can come here and be
all the way black on a lot of jobs you
don't get to express yourself you have
to contain that Blackness you have to
put on your uh corporate put your
corporate out
yeah but here you can come here you can
tell all the lies you want you can be
the person you want to be you can come
and tell your and bear your truth this
is that last place that we have for that
and I wouldn't I wouldn't want to not
have that yeah I would B of Amer fre
that's yeah yeah you know I've been
getting my I've been getting my haircut
my whole damn life I've never had this
tell it's not it's not the same thing
see I've never I've always assumed that
you know when the white guys go into bar
I've always assumed that it's like the
mafia mov when you see them in there
getting their haircut they in there
talking with the hot ey on yeah I feel
like guine from New York yeah see that's
I've always Envision that's what must be
what the white barers shop is like like
you said because there are sub SE of
white of White America they might have
that that the general populace may not
actually get to
occup no I think it's it's healthy I
mean imagine just kind of if you do this
how let's say how often does a customer
come in here on average once every you
going either get a weekly Buy weekly
monthly that's generally that's the
that's the general okay most people
probably come in like every two weeks
maybe every two weeks is probably most
consistent think of how valuable it is
like a reset you know what I mean you're
having a bad week you're having a bad
two weeks you come in you see familiar
faces you can talk imagine you're going
10 20 years and you never have that
that's what we're seeing yeah that will
suck country oh yeah it's terrible that
would that will suck you know because
these guys you know each and every one
of us carry our own experiences and our
own op and some sometimes it's just good
to hear a different opinion on what's
something you're dealing with or
something you want to know about you
know yes this guy over here he might be
well versed in something that I'm having
a question or issue with and he able to
really just drop some game on and I
really don't even know him yeah but he
can just say that and he can be comfort
and he feels comfortable enough in here
to express himself the conversation we
having about the about the alphabet Mar
you can't have this conversation
everywhere without fear retri and you
see you know that you're experimenting
with it by talking to people you know
you get you know people get turned
sideways when you you know if they feel
offended but this is one place you going
to have to check your feelings at the
door when you come in this yeah cuz you
going to get a lot of real nobody's
going to be uh I don't want to say
insensitive but nobody's going to be uh
we're not here to Badger you or to
disrespect you but you going to get a
dop and a level of truth from this place
that you're not going to get in a whole
lot of plac and we pride oursel on it
that's one of our models nobody makes we
don't let nobody
make yeah you you don't need to I've
been I've been in enough green rooms
with yeah we
got turn up and just walked in but I
appreciate the fact that you had had the
wellwith all to want to come and get
this perspective oh yeah we do this we
do this all what happened would be you'd
have so many like if we discussed
affirmative action for example like on
campus I think we did SMU you'd have a
bunch of screaming white people telling
you about the black community and I
would go but none of you are in the
black community so we just I just
started saying like let me just go to
the black community and they'd like no
that's we don't they don't
speak for us they would they would say
we don't agree with that opinion at all
and uh that's the problem most people
have they're not willing to see it from
the other side yeah you know just like
he said you open my eyes on a lot of
white perspective just in the time
you've been in here the white male thing
you know I've never been one so it's a
lot I don't understand because the lack
of community I never thought about that
yeah I never thought that a white guy
could goow his most to his life and not
have a click or or a spot where he can
come and really truly just let his hair
down and be vulnerable cuz that's what
most people don't recognize so you can
come in here and tell tell you know come
in here and tell your ball man I lost my
job today man damn I don't know what I'm
going do and without fear of being
judged in that aspect yeah I know that
you that that that a white guy might not
really have that that that place he
could go Express that I didn't
understand I didn't know you'll get it
like you know military and that's why
you see you know you see black white
like if you're in the military you're
all in it together or you'll see it like
in certain Sports so like uh you know
coming from like a like uh grappling
background if I go into a new new city
it's like okay I can go to a I can go to
go to grappling school and we're going
to have something in common it's now
it's not a race thing it's just we all
share this in hard training getting your
joints blown out and all that stuff you
know cuz you're wrestling dudes like
wrestling teams I'm sure it's the same
with football or I mean in Canada hockey
it's like you these guys just they bleed
for each other but as far as just dayto
day like once you're out of college once
you're okay you don't have sports
anymore you don't have a school to go to
anymore yeah where do I find that
commonality they drop off that Community
aspect if they're not doing Church like
you were saying faith if you don't have
church what is it it's nothing you
standing on an island by yourself trying
to navigate yeah that's that's something
that I think you know beyond the whether
black white like just we need to get
back to communities strong communities
of people care about each other man
absolutely all right I'm going get going
anyways yeah you guys talk about you
have this the only place to be truly
black and then I looked in the mirror
I'm like oh my gosh I'm the whitest
human being on Earth he probably thought
I was a narc no I think I think he got
to beat oh yeah well that guy's not
white he's
transparent he would make Larry Bird
look at him and be like dude can you
black it up a little
bit hey thanks thanks what your I'm Big
Mike man m is everyone big here big Phil
Big M what's your name
Andrey Doug thanks dou oh don don I
thought you said Doug all right Don do
hey Don how you go like the Don who was
it man sorry Travis nice to meet you man
I appreciate what's your name whitest
guy on Earth grant grant sorry giving
you a tough time
[Music]
thanks remember none of this is possible
without you join the fight and sign up
for mug Club today at
louderwithcrowder.com mugclub for $89
annually join the fight at lwith cr.com
mugclub today